[Music]
At first I didn't like to spend a
lot of time underwater because it scared me,
my mother always made me suffer because
she let go of
my base in the water and she
swam backwards then I never never
reached her
to practice the measurement you have to be
totally brought up by the problems
you have
[Music
] my family doesn't like it because they
really have always thought that it is a
dangerous sport and I have the
habit of practicing the sport only
that you never have to do it
during  the nine months that we are in
the womb because we are
always submerged in a liquid
so
that state of disconnection and security provides it directly
[Music]
your heartbeat slows down
as soon as your face
connects with the water
the sensation of weightlessness is similar
to which people feel when they
free fall or an astronaut
[Music]
the days of total stillness you hear your
own heart beating underwater
[Music]
you will always know another
world a different world there are no laws
that rule on earth
[Music]
x
well
[Music]